do you think I'm a better cook than you
no she says our apartment is her home
and I'm lucky to be a guest okay I get
that from my mother though where you're
like get your feet off of my tables I'll
have it's just I understand it's our
table instead of causing like a friction
our tension-filled moment I'll just let
him hear what he wants to hear I've made
people cry because I've just been honest
worst case scenario like to the extreme
is that yeah four months to go so we saw
time to call off the wedding we got that
deposit down I bought a dress so like
the wedding's happening but it's whether
or not we'll stay together after the
wedding which is up for debate
have you ever masturbated in bed while I
was sleeping next to you yes true
okay do you actually want sex kids or
are you just messing with me yes yeah
that's true
oh sweet do you think I need to lose
weight no true Oh have you ever wanted
to break up with me yes yeah that's true
okay so you wanted to break up with me a
lot of times and I didn't count that was
like the first few months do you think
we'll get divorced no true
do you actually think that you're a
better driver than I am yes true that is
such bull I I am you're a horrible
driver
no never got into an accident you
crashed our car like right before
Christmas it's five kids too much
no false it'll destroy my body do you
feel like we will stay together forever
yes
it's true are you fine with me never
being a millionaire yes true have you
ever been worried about or regretted
dating a white guy No
that's false no like I'm honest wait
what do you mean like in specific like I
believe in warrens about I can do the
worry just by itself but like have you
been worried about it no not like
worried worried do you like my style
yeah true
that's why I buy you clothes it's good
to know what he thinks and that what he
says is real and I still love you no
need to call off the wedding
honesty is great and if your partner can
laugh about with you and be honest about
stuff I think that's great that's all
you need I don't think I could have
relied to you I think yeah I think you
would know it was nerve-wracking at
times and but it was fun and I'm like
this I feel like worse weirdly closer
together disconfirmed that I know that
I'm marrying an honest and and stand-up
guy and I found the right man for me Oh
look and I can't wait to be your wife I
can't wait to be your wife